[Applause]
Prince Harry is fabulous with kids and
he's about to have his own I've longed
the kid since I was very very young and
so I'm just waiting to find the right
person that was Harry in 2012 he's
wanted to be a father
for so long which is why we know he's
perfect for the job
I'd love to have kids right now I can't
wait for the day me and being a dad yeah
you know one thing at a time one thing
at a time
we'll start a family that's forward to
October 15 2018 and we also generally
couldn't think of a better place to
announce the upcoming baby five months
after Harry and Megan tied the knot the
palace announced that the former actress
was expecting and Harry's longing for
kids turned to gushing about his
pregnant wife and their little bun in
the oven
Prince Harry's had lots of practice you
know my godfather that's quite a few of
my friends actually only five or six
maybe you like a really awesome
Godfather I'd like to think so but you
know I I think the key to that is to
grow up but also be able to stay in
touch with your child yeah you taught it
aside and if that means getting
someone's house to say now I'm playing
PlayStation and kicking the app to their
son on counter-strike or or Halo or
whatever it is that I'll try and do that
you're also uncle Harry to two little
ones that are running around you've got
to have fun in life otherwise well
imagine life without fun you've got to
be taken seriously but obviously before
pink blue B was born but we have no
doubt about the fun uncle part one thing
I'm nice to see is you all really really
good with kids
Harry isn't just good with children he
is a big kid at heart
[Music]
and he obviously adores them
the Duke of Sussex is already looking
out for his kids future as someone who
is about to become a father I'm acutely
aware of our shared responsibility to
make this world more resilient and its
inhabitants more accountable for the
next generation
Megan Marco is reason number five
whether they're attending a fancy Gala
or rolling up their sleeves and getting
to work the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
seem to have a solid partnership perfect
for parenting we're a fantastic team we
know real and princess diana is our
reason number six
she fiercely loved her boys and was an
excellent role model when Terry was very
little boy and he came into the kitchen
one morning at about 6:30
asking for a treacle tart so I sent him
off and I said oh I think you better go
and check this mummy before and see what
what she says and he came back just a
few moments later clutching a tiny
little piece of paper and Princess Diana
had written on that mummy says it's okay
that was very typical of her just yeah
just loved her little boy so much and
loved to have fun with them and from the
looks of it Harry will be the theme with
his little one